in 2018 chances are that everyone has
multiple favorite Netflix movies and TV
shows and the source of a safe bet that
everyone is super excited for upcoming
Netflix originals that are arriving on a
wave of hype but with so much new
content added to the streamer every day
it's impossible to keep track of
everything thus some future movies and
shows have fallen under the radar even
though they actually feature big stars
and buzz worthy premises let's take a
closer look at upcoming Netflix
originals that nobody is talking about
yet the chilling Adventures of Sabrina
Riverdale executive producer Roberto
aguirre-sacasa is bringing Sabrina the
Teenage Witch to Netflix although she
won't be anything like Melissa Joan Hart
version this version is based on the
comic series chilling Adventures of
Sabrina which tells a dark origin story
for the witty teen the show follows
Sabrina played by Mad Men's Kiernan
Shipka as she tries to balance being
half witch and half mortal or fighting
against evil forces chilling adventures
already has a two season twenty episode
order so expect quite a lot of magical
mishaps in Greendale after it premieres
on October 26th and hopefully a
Riverdale crossover auto Russian doll
natasha Lyonne has already had success
with a Netflix hit earning an Emmy
nomination for her work on orange is the
new black she's set to team up with the
streamer once again for Russian doll but
she co-created with Amy Poehler and
sleeping with other people director
Leslie headland the eight episode series
stars Leone is a young woman named Nadia
who throughout one endless night serves
as a guest of honor at a seemingly
inescapable partay the show has been
described as an ambitious and uniquely
formatted comedy that will have viewers
guessing as much as they will be
laughing with that description and the
incredibly talented cast this is shaping
up to be one of your new favorite shows
da de la la la director Damien Chazelle
is getting back into the musical game
the Oscar winner is set to executive
produce and direct two episodes of the
musical drama series the Eddy which is
set in modern-day multicultural Paris it
will revolve around a jazz club with
American and French Arab co-owners the
show will tell the story of a club its
owner the house band and the chaotic
city that surrounds them the Eddy will
be shot in France with dialogue and
French
English and Arabic the 8 episode series
also has BAFTA award-winning writer Jack
thorn on board as well as Grammy
award-winning composer Glen Ballard
writing the original score
Dolly Parton anthology Dolly Parton is
one of the greatest songwriters who's
ever lived
she's had a hand in penning almost all
of her memorable hits including I will
always love you 9 to 5 coat of many
colors and Jolene she has a knack for
composing songs I feel like we all
people are singing about real situations
and Netflix is going to turn some of
those into narrative films in 2018 the
service announced plans for an 8 part
anthology series in which each episode
will be a self-contained story based on
one of Parsons Tunes in a press
statement the singer said we hope our
show will inspire and entertain families
and folks at all generations parts and
while executive producer series as well
as briefly appear in a few episodes
sunshine Scouts after more than a decade
creating hit shows for ABC television
juggernaut Shonda Rhimes signed the deal
in April 2018 to bring her shondaland
brand to Netflix three months later the
prolific Rhimes announced that she and
her crew were at work on a whopping 8
different series including dramas
documentaries and even a pitch black
half hour comedy called sunshine Scouts
overseen by Rimes Burke created by
writer actress Jill Alexander the series
takes place after an event of
apocalyptic proportions destroys a great
deal of civilization and life on Earth a
group of teenage girl scouts at a summer
camp have to band together to thrive in
this brave new world they abide by
sunshine Scout law and use have many
scouting skills to find food and shelter
and avoid nuclear fallout Norm Macdonald
has a show
finally Norma Donald arguably the
greatest talk show guest ever will host
his own talk show the one-of-a-kind
comedian will soon be inviting guests to
talk to and mark as Norm Macdonald has a
show premieres September 14th following
David Letterman Chelsea Handler and
Michelle wolf McDonald joins the Netflix
lineup of late-night talk shows you can
watch any time it'll be a co showrunner
in addition to hosting and his sidekick
will be Adam egit his co-host on the
Nour MacDonald life podcast the initial
guest lineup includes drew Barrymore
David Spade Judge Judy David Letterman
Jane Fonda
be chase and like Shyamalan Michael
Keaton Billy Joe shaver and Lorne
Michaels turn up Charlie
after stepping away from the small
screen for a while to appear in multiple
movie franchises aegis elbow will return
to television with an edgy comedy called
turnip Charlie he co-created the show
and it's about a topic close to his
heart
electronic music elbows a DJ in real
life and the show is about an aging
bachelor and EDM DJ who agrees to be a
caretaker for a celebrity best friends
of noxious young daughter turnip Charlie
should turn up on Netflix in late 2018
or 2019
[Music]